[music] of
this size, we just came up with it, he
put his head down there Nine
years ago, let's see
[music]
[applause]
how much [
music]
you understand all this [music
]
yourself live
[music]
on which
I don't know the final decision
[  music]
during today's dawn there
are
exceptional results looked at in
relation to Navalny
some turn gray
[music] the
Russian Federation according to the script And that
it is the one who defends the accused against us
thoroughly
[music]
people who affect Navalny's
defenders
[music]
14-27.02046 a  also
magic 23 years stopped 500
million cost
[music]
the station
is clear even the court decision
[music]
but
[music] the
second string
[music] is
incomprehensible
[music]